well congratulations tonight is a really
big night for you mister are you ready
for it no
no well you better get ready you got
from here to there to get ready miss
well thank you very much i'm excited to
perform really tell us more about this
performance because you're performing
with justin bieber right yeah i'm gonna
be performing on mountains and i'm
flying from the sky no you're not yeah
whoa anything can happen at the vmas is
it gonna make uh you know a vma kind of
moment you know the vmas is known for
its moment
i don't know dude maybe who knows we'll
see how that goes oh my gosh what has it
been like working with justin getting to
know him has he provided you with a
little bit of advice along the way yeah
he's the best um he's always provided me
with advice i i really like we've only
known each other for like maybe close to
a year now but um i look at that dude
like family and um
he actually gave me some advice last
night about today so what did he say to
you it's more personal but along the
lines of just like you know protects
your energy
i think that's really great advice and
he's lived it he's experienced it you
know agreed to agree to agree okay give
me the fashion here y'all keep
forgetting your shirts tonight young man
uh well where are these shirts you gotta
show off the mavs uh no no no so my my
shutter my shirt i got a stain on it so
i had to leave it in the car
just like a kid yeah kids love rolling i
got pizza on it joe's
pizza i did splash it all over did you
really let me see
oh yeah
what does it say i love new york yep
this one is uh
uh oh
not for daisy this one is a ghost and
this one says safe sex
well and uh you know it's important um
it's a skull it's a web
you know is this gel
yes so no so it's hand painted oh i
don't even have the patience for that
yeah 1-800 nail me that's her name she
did it no no that's her name that's the
mushroom dinner yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's a great shout out that's a
great have fun tonight and
congratulations thank you
you're a trap man
you